some people like to voluntarily play
games that scare the living daylights
out of them it's that magical time of
year for us to look ahead into the
future at the creepiest scariest most
upsetting games on the horizon
you remember out last one don't you well
that first person survival with a
handycam is back and creepier than ever
with new foes to run from you're in the
Arizona desert and looking into the
murder of a Jane Doe just like in the
first game you can't fight so you'll be
hiding in lockers and cornfields and
troughs of questionable water with
nothing but a camera that tends to run
low on batteries at the worst times the
gameplay they've shown shows the main
character avoiding aggressive villagers
only to come face-to-face with worse
evils this is most definitely something
you'll want on your radar with the
current release window of q1 2017 this
one might have snuck up on you but hello
neighbor is the perfect blend of stealth
and horror you live in a pleasant and
quiet community but there's something
wrong with your neighbor so it's up to
you to sneak into his house undetected
and look for clues to what lurks beneath
you'll try and trick him into going
outside and then keep him busy while you
look for ways to get into that basement
but if he finds you game over it's you
against the neighbors in summer 2017
chances are you've played a Resident
Evil game before but this one is a bit
different you're headed to a plantation
in Louisiana home of the lovely Baker
family but they're serving something
questionable for supper Resident Evil is
known for mixing it up but it's in first
person and what's more it has VR support
gosh you're not just sneaking around
you're being squished between walls and
hiding under floorboards with surprising
twists around every corner you meet the
Baker's January 24 2017
System Shock really captivated players
back in the mid-90s but this complete
remake will take you back to citadel
state in a game that doesn't just look
better it's been retooled for a truly
horrific experience and for anyone new
to System Shock you're going to want to
try this you're in a space station
littered with cyborgs and mutated crew
members and you'll eventually face off
one of the most upsetting AI villains
you'll ever encounter if it's got Jason
Voorhees in it it's already won me over
but let me paint you a picture for why
you should care this is a 1 v7 survival
game where you can play as a camp
counselor working with your friends to
avoid the wrath of Jason himself or you
can take on the role of the psycho
killer from Camp Crystal Lake violently
taking out each counselor one by one and
it's beautifully brutal the developers
have added some nice touches like Jason
getting stronger as the night progresses
you can even play as various versions of
Jason from the movies currently slated
for an early release in 2017 you can
start taking out those sex-crazed teens
however you please
and that's our list for the top five
scary games on the horizon what are you
looking forward to let us know in the
comments below thanks for watching